and into that same point at t and apple
know where your phone is at all times
right and if they need to get to you
they can
um and that's that gets used
appropriately at times so i think
for us it's about drawing our own lines
you know i have a very diverse company
in terms of
politics religion or everything
everything we have covered and
we have to set our own boundaries that
we get comfortable with because
there's a right way to solve crime and
there's a wrong way
and we're trying to do the right way
um facebook has had an issue with their
employees
uh stalking and looking at private
messages location data
et cetera all down the line over the
years
multiple cases of engineers doing this
basically stalking
ex-girlfriends or uh and it's 100 men
doing it so far to the best of my
knowledge in the cases i've seen
um you are now the owner of
a set of data that is ginormous
how do you ensure that your employees do
not stock
their exes or otherwise compromise your
data
yeah so there's there's both a legal
component and then an operational
component so the legal component
is all i'll make one minor modification
to your statement we're actually not the
owner
so from a legal perspective it's not our
data we are the custodian of it you know
from a hosting perspective but
legally myself my engineers anyone
have no legal right to go look at the
data okay but you technically can
because you would have to tweet the
algorithm at times and look at it so
we're in the
sort of alexa category way so it is
encrypted though
so an engineer would have to go
incredibly rogue
and i'm not even sure technically how
they would pull this off would have to
then go
unencrypt that image which i don't think
they could actually do
okay um and then go pull it and they're
they're now pulling their hand
if one of your customers you know in san
ramon said hey
we think something's not working here
the license plates are doing ones for
l's
uh you can't even go look at their data
set so here's the operational piece so
there's a legal piece of like we
we can't go access it in bulk an
operational component is
we do provide customer support and so
the only thing
anyone on my staff can see is the last
image captured
so that if someone does call and say hey
you know there was a hurricane down in
florida and our
our camera's really foggy it's like
really like so we can pull that last
image
and say like it is foggy we will go yeah
we're gonna try go find their ex
girlfriend or ex-wife's you know exactly
yeah yeah yeah so you've there's no god
like other companies
have unfortunately built at times and
had to undo
because the uh in looking at the eff's
position
and they tend to take a pretty all or
nothing
they believe there should be no license
plate reading uh services
that's right is their position because
uh just looking at their site
location i'll just read from their site
location-based information like license
plate data can be very revealing by
matching your card to a particular
particular time date
location and then building a database of
that information over time law
enforcement can learn where you work and
live what doctor you go to which
religious services you've done
and who your friends are but in this
statement of
how they're framing the discussion they
the overtime is a key component here and
the overtime is 90 days
at best and you're not
you do have location but you don't have
pictures of the driver so
yeah which is no location through their
objection haven't you
well i just think look like i i like you
i'm a normal person
that's a citizen in america that wants
to continue living in a country that has
these same ideals
and i think we also want to live in a
place that's safe
yeah and so there's got to be a world
where we can have both of these yeah and
i think the part where i tend to
disagree with the eff and the aclu is
like
they're talking about a world where
literally our police departments can't
do their job
we're going to give them no tools no
technology we're going to give them a
you know a rabbit's foot and say good
luck out there
and i just think that's a bit misguided
when there are ways
to enforce transparency and
accountability and give
tools so yeah i agree i think my team
and myself
put a lot of energy into how to build
this so that
every city regardless of politics or
wealth level
can be safe got it and there are other
uh services vigilance solutions learn
system
that includes billions of license plates
and uh and they are selling that service
maybe you could speak to
you know uh their approach versus yours
yeah i mean
they are the incumbents that in my
opinion kind of
took a wrong turn they sell their data
they store it forever
the majority of their revenue comes from
data sales
not from solving crime and so they
actually take all that aggregated data
and sell it to anyone who has the right
price
and i think that's a really slippery
slope
yeah um vigilant solutions is your
competitor
i guess yep that's our largest
competitor do they
make the the like real-time license
plate scanning stuff as well
or they just start the database more the
their their primary focus is the
database
they have a camera but you know the
biggest difference is you and i were
talking about
we obviously read the license plate but
what we really pick up is what we call
the vehicle fingerprint
so some criminals are smart enough to
take off their license plate
yep we're still going to pick up your
make your model perfect what kind of
stickers you have
do you have damage do you have a roof
rack do you have aftermarket tires like
we're looking across exactly how our
detective would
and so we can provide that same type of
search experience so there was a recent
case
where it was a drive-by shooting in a
town the
criminal was smart had no license plate
but wasn't that smart
because he drove that exact same car
through the neighborhood two days
earlier
to case it and so with our system they
could easily do a lookalike search and
say hey i'm looking for that exact same
car have we seen it
oh yes we have and there it is with a
license plate on the exact same road
so with a traditional system you can't
do something like that
and yeah so you don't want to be in
vigilance business and vigilance
business
is truly scary i would be with the aclu
on
going after vigilant and i think the
aclu should be actually pro
what you're doing vigilant has
according to the wall street journal
more than 30 license plate scans for
every registered vehicle on the nation's
roads today
so they have 30 moments in time for
everybody's car
that seems like mass surveillance and a
private company should not be allowed to
do it
what you're doing seems amazing and
people should be able to do it
obviously clearview ai scraped social
media for a billion faces we had them on
the program
i also think the tracking of who uses
this because
you have i'm certain a log of every time
law enforcement
looks up license plates and they can't
turn their logs off
today many small business owners are
busier than ever
since they're focused on managing and
growing their business they can't always
spend the time they wish they could on
recruiting and you're only as good as
your team i talk about that all the time
on this podcast
and that's why linkedin jobs has made it
easier
to find and hire the best candidates for
free get started
by posting your job for free to reach
linkedin's network of
740 million professionals oh my god
there's a lot of people on linkedin fill
out targeted screening questions to get
your role
in front of the most qualified
candidates with the experience skills
and motivation
you need then it's easy to filter and
prioritize the top candidates you'd like
to interview
we love linkedin jobs at launch and at
inside we've hired a second producer
a curriculum designer and a few more
researchers
we are crushing it we're now 18 people
here i can't believe it it used to be me
and like three people
every week nearly 40 million job seekers
visit linkedin
if you've got a job you're going to find
those job seekers on linkedin
and they're going to find that right
person for your role right now
don't waste time post your first job for
free that's right free linkedin is so
supportive of this podcast
that they're gonna let you post your
first job for free to prove to you
how amazing their product is that's how
confident they are linkedin.com
unicorn that's linkedin.com unicorn
to post your first job listing for free